J Moore actor-comedian check out Jays
new show America's Lakers podcast this
is the team's official podcast available
on podcast one sports.com the new
podcast one app and Apple podcasts look
at you Jay Mohr your official good to
have you back how are you how are you
I'm good I'm great I'm happy to talk
with Dan Patrick and crew and let me
tell you something when that alarm goes
off it's for Dan Patrick show doesn't
matter baby you go get it I like it
how did you become the official podcast
of the Lakers we mean Aaron our soul
we're doing this podcast for podcast one
and norm pattice and obviously you have
to get the blessing of the team to be
the official podcast of the Los Angeles
Lakers and I think there's probably you
know if we're speaking frankly a bit of
a little bit of a longer vetting process
when it's me on the mic because you
don't want to endorse a podcast where
the guys gonna go hey what's gonna say
something awful but it's look it's
Lakers basketball it is the greatest
show in town I mean last year opening
night against the Rockets that was a 17
win team and I was listening to John
Ireland on the radio here and I was like
oh my gosh this is incredible I'd knots
in my stomach it was a half hour before
tip-off and it really hit me this is the
biggest brand on earth like this is you
know what's Lakers cowboys Yankees and
so the to be able to do a podcast for a
my favorite team and be for a team that
where everybody's about 14 and a half
years old there's like two bar mitzvahs
coming up at half-time gonna be great
he's a man how did you wait why are we
on the Tony Bennett kick here cuz norm
pilots a podcast one is obsessed with me
join coach Tony fan
Jr took a leak yes I don't know there
was a mini heart attack I don't want to
say the wrong thing because it's medical
remember that ones during the tournament
yeah Tony Pettit and the Cavaliers took
a knee and he was trending on Twitter
for having you know taking a knee and
the Tony Bennett the singer having zero
knowledge of anything just tweeted out
it comes to me at the Bogata field in
Atlantic City oh my gosh let's go to one
fold-flat read everybody brothers go to
the RET and I've got about 15,000
retweets is very next tweet was my heart
goes out to Nancy on the like Sinatra
jr. that had 40 retweets now when you do
a podcast as the official podcast
America's Lakers podcast do people want
to hear the negative with the Lakers I
think that's where I come in with my
best discernible skill as you remember
from a bee radio or the more stories
podcast I don't know a lot of room in me
for the negative there's enough negative
without creating it I saw something on
dude yes is the answer but they're not
gonna get it here okay I saw an article
that the Lakers are ranked seventh in
defense but can they sustain it why why
why that one sentence why can't we
celebrate a bunch of you know 21 years
these guys this is the young young team
far exceeding expectations and it's
exciting like if this was a stock dad
Patrick the Godfather the man my man you
wouldn't want to buy Laker stock if this
was a business if this was a restaurant
if this was a hedge fund
you know warrior stocks gonna give you
about a 1% return and for how long I
can't promise you this Lakers team this
is coca-cola stock in 1955 this list
ceiling not potential that's a dirty
word my man you know Bernie Williams
never had it Gerald Williams retired
with it
I don't like potential but just feeling
on this team is inexplicably high and I
personally never seen it in my lifetime
in any sport honestly but when I look I
watched him last night and I want i
watch with reasonable expectations and I
watch Lonzo ball with reasonable
expectations or Ingram or Kuzma or
Clarkson or Lopez I don't expect them to
be more than a 30 to win team at most
but what you want to see is do they pass
the ball
do they like Lonzo does everybody get
together do they play hard together
those are the things I'm looking for
when I'm watching them but people are
going to watch Lanza if Lanza ball
nobody knew Lanza ball let's say he came
in like John Stockton nobody knew who he
was he would be the guy that everybody
is saying hey that guy ball was pretty
good like he's a lot of fun to watch
there and and he doesn't have that
benefit so when you watch you still come
away gone yeah he was okay yeah he did
okay almost a triple but he's gonna have
that the entire season and I think that
Jade's the view of what we see with the
Lakers your thoughts Jay Mohr and let me
make it really clear Jen like I'm not a
guy that's gonna put rose-colored
glasses on everything like the last
episode we did there's we got into the
Julius Randle cloud that's been created
and the confounding you know everything
around this is just confounding that
woes goes out talks about Julius Randle
before tip-off you talk about anything
you talk about the weather and the
Maldives or something but that was like
the lead story he won't be here you're
like why not for four-and-a-half million
dollars I'm gonna ride that Jaguars
alloy wheels fall off you know so I need
that to be clear like I'm not like
everything's great all the time like
we're pretty pragmatic when it comes to
the team lonzo's got more assistant
Damian Lillard yeah look up my thing is
good at point guard as Damian Lillard by
a long stretch we've got more assistant
you know Kemba Walker he's got more I
said because I saw somebody doesn't let
go he's not an NBA point guard
I even saw where somebody said they
should bench him no they this is where
you get to play him you have patience
with him instead of said oh you got to
bench him if his confidence is it is low
which I do see a little bit of that he's
hesitant on the offensive end then
that's a concern but I want him out
there I just want to make your mistakes
go play man you have to shoot yourself
out of not being able to shoot you know
but yeah I don't know if he's hesitant
Dennis I just shot in all fairness does
look like an oil derrick on La Cienega
he might not be creaking and groaning on
the podcast I mean I don't really plan
on it okay it's not who did you play for
he well he could play for any team
apparently of course I would have all
the Lakers podcast I was loved as by the
way this is a he's got well what kid
just got arrested in China but that sort
of throws the father
III think he's a very good father in a
society where fathers are sort of hard
to find slot come by and hang on to the
fact that over present sort of speaks a
little more to him actually being pretty
good at it
and yeah is he like Randy rowdy roddy
piper and he wanted to sort of dial it
back to at least a Don Muraco level of
yeah but yeah love devil of our ball the
podcast absolutely I want those seats
Coby get Coby on the podcast Coby yeah
of course
oh you on the podcast I'm looking at on
my kidding Jay let's do it get get the
tape rolling now let's do the podcast
right now on my show
[Music]
why can't you pass out when the ball
slide it along good Lopez there's 8
minutes have a seat and you Logan yeah I
did have a little sandler twist in there
he's Jay Mohr
check out his new show America's Lakers
podcast although I'm not big on that
it's just the Lakers official podcast
like America's Lakers are there too many
answers in okay yeah to take it up with
the boss let me say this though Aaron
Laura Sewell my co-host is the most
brilliant analytical mind I've ever sat
next to wow I'm smarter each episode and
I always feel pretty smart going in and
I gave you my word man I'm not gonna
pull punches this is my passion Dan I
love doing this podcast and it's like
the Lakers now coca-cola stock 1955 if
you don't want to buy it now don't come
at me in a year whatever looking
fantastic
America's Lakers podcast that's a sort
of a working title it's the official
Laker podcast available on podcast one
sports.com
and the new podcast app and apple
podcast also can you leave us with a
little Christopher walk in there know
who you are
shoot the free I don't care just on the
shot from the shower
hoist it check out maybe the food and
that's crazy Luke I got hey good luck
with this if you want me on the podcast
I'm there please say hello to Jeannie
bus for us and I'm ready to go whenever
you need me that's a lady boss oh my get
in touch with Paulie Paulie path
absolutely I love you very much thank
you all right that's a jay mohr he's the
official host of the official Laker
podcast there for more Dan Patrick show
too
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]